all right uh so uh next we're happy to
have tell us about for a growth of xor
fibers of communication protocols
um
yes so I'll be talking about this topic
and this is based on joint work with
makrand avishai and Kevin
so there are a lot of buzzwords in this
title so I'm going to start by defining
these Concepts so first let's look at
Fourier growth
given a Boolean function the level L
mass of a function is defined to be the
sum of absolute values of level L
Fourier coefficients
Fourier growth refers to the growth of
the level L mass and by Fourier growth
bonds we mean upper bounds on the level
L Mass
intuitively speaking functions with
small Fourier growth cannot aggregate
many weak signals in the output to have
a cons in the input to have a
considerable effect on the output
in contrast the majority function is an
example of a function with large Fourier
growth this is a function that can
distinguish between inputs that are just
slightly biased towards one versus
slightly biased towards minus one
so this is what Fourier growth tries to
capture
it turns out that Fourier growth bonds
have applications in many areas
so in the field of quantum versus
classical separations it turns out that
Fourier growth is exactly the key
distinguishing concept between Quantum
and classical
it turns out that Quantum algorithms can
compute functions that have large
Fourier growth but classical algorithms
cannot
Fourier growth bonds have also been
studied in the context of pseudorandom
generators
so roughly functions with small Fourier
growth are easy to fool
the original motivation for studying
Fourier growth months was actually in
learning theory where it was shown that
functions with small total Fourier
growth are easy to learn
these are the various motivations for
studying Fourier growth months and
Fourier growth has been studied for a
large number of models which I've
described in this slide two models that
we will be interested in and we'll
revisit in the stock are parity decision
place and decision trees
for this model we have optimal Fourier
growth bonds yes
what do you mean
so this is a very loose concept but
essentially you can so your methodical
function can distinguish whether your
inputs have bias 1 over square rooted
towards one or minus one this is what
they call a weak signal and the maturity
can distinguish this
n
and in order to detect the signal you
need to have large Fourier growth
so
so yeah
decision please
in general getting optimal figure out
bonds is a very challenging problem even
for the first few levels
uh it really requires understanding the
structure of these functions
there are many open problems regarding
Fourier growth and the problem we are
interested in is Fourier growth of XR
fibers so now let me say what xor fibers
are
so even a communication protocol you can
Define the xor fiber as follows
you look at the average output of the
protocol
over all X comma y such that x x or y
equals z
call this h of Z
so H is the xor fiber
so the picture is as follows you can
view the communication protocol as this
Matrix where you have Alice's inputs and
Bob's inputs you're looking at the
diagonal of X comma y he says that the
xor equals z and you're taking the
average of the protocol
this is what we call the XR fiber of the
protocol
so although this XR fiber seems to be a
name that hasn't appeared before in
literature this has been implicitly
studied in many areas especially the
area of xor lifting
so in the situation of XR lifting it's
kind of the reverse of an xor fiber here
you have a Boolean function and you're
defining a communication problem where
Alice want Alice and Bob want to compute
this function on the xor of their inputs
more formally given a function H you can
define a communication problem where
Alice gets X Bob gets Y and they want to
compute h of X X or Y
so this is the XR lift of Boolean
function
and functions of communication problems
of this form are called Excel problems
and they are very well studied in
communication complexity
it's not too hard to see that this xor
lift and xor fiber are kind of reverses
of each other
in the sense that if you have a
communication protocol that exactly
computes the xor lift of some function h
if you compute the xor fiber of this
protocol it is exactly h
so this is what we mean by an xor fiber
and our goal is to study the Fourier
growth of xor fibers
let me start by describing the
motivation for studying this Fourier
growth of xor fibers and there are many
motivations
so one motivation is uh with the with
respect to lifting theorems for constant
size gadgets
so it's widely open to get any lifting
theorem where the Gadget size is
constant
and any such lifting theorem would imply
Fourier growth bounds on xor fibers
if you get the optimal lifting theorem
it would imply the optimal Fourier
growth bond for extra fibers
so in some sense all constant size
gadgets you can embed the xor gadget in
them so really this follows as an
implication of lifting theorem to the
constances gets its which is a major
open question
uh it turns out that there are some
applications of Fourier growth bounds
for Excel fibers in these three areas
which I'll now describe
so first what is the connection with
parity decision trees and standard
decision piece it turns out that
decision trees are a special class of
xor fibers
in the sense that given any decision
tree you can produce a communication
protocol of twice the cost such that the
xor fiber of that protocol is exactly
the decision to be
therefore parity decision trees and
standard decision trees are a special
type of xor fibers
so if you want to understand Fourier
growth effects or fibers we first need
to understand Fourier growth of decision
trees and parity decision trees
although these models are very studied
interestingly it was only recently that
people understood the exact Fourier
growth Bonds on these models
we now have a good understanding on the
Fourier growth of these two models
so this is one reason to study xor
fibers there are generalization of these
models
the second connection is to Quantum
versus classical separations in
communication complexity
so for this let me start by telling you
the situation in query complexity
so inquiry complexity there's this
problem called the k-fold formulation
problem
and this problem was used to separate
Quantum query complexity and classical
query complexity
so in particular it was shown that this
problem has a Quantum protocol with Q
over two queries but every randomized
protocol requires like n to the 1 minus
one over K queries
it turns out that the key concept used
to show the separation was Fourier
growth bonds so in particular this work
by bansal and Sinha showed that any
problem that solves k for correlation
any model that solves K4 for relation
must have large level K Fourier growth
we already saw in the previous slide
that decision trees have small Fourier
growth as a result it follows that
Precision trees classical decision trees
cannot solve the k-fold correlation
problem
this is also an optimal separation in
the sense any Quantum algorithm with
these many queries can be classically
simulated with these many queries
so this is an optimal separation in
query complexity
now we ask what about communication
complexity
so it turns out that you can lift the
separation from the query complexity
world to the communication complexity
World using this inner product Gadget
and that gives you a problem in
communication with a small cost Quantum
protocol with K rounds but every
classical protocol requires
communication into the one minus one
over k
now we ask is this an optimal separation
can you get a better separation
so we suspect that this separation is
not optimal and that's really because
you're using the inner product Gadget
the hope is that if you lift this
problem this formulation problem with
the xor gadget you will get a similar
separation quantitatively but the
quantum protocol will require only half
as many rounds
so one example of this is if you look at
the case k equals 2 this previous result
only gives you a separation between
two-way Quantum protocols and classical
protocols and one can ask can you get a
separation between one-way Quantum
protocols and
um classical protocols with the same
kind of quantitative Gap
and the hope is that if you do exercise
if you lift to the xor gadget you will
get to the separation indeed the xor
gadget is much simpler than in a product
Gadget so if you look at formulation
lifted with xor it has a Quantum
protocol with half the number of rounds
in particular the two-fold formulation
has a Quantum has a one-way Quantum
protocol in fact it has a Quantum
simultaneous protocol which is even
weaker than one-way Quantum protocol
so the question is then what about the
lower bound if you lift with xor gets it
does the same kind of lower Bond hold
and to do this you really need to
understand Fourier growth for xor fibers
okay
so the last motivation for this I'm
going to talk about is the connection
with The Gap farming problem
so this gap having problem is a famous
problem in communication complexity
it has applications to streaming lower
bonds and so on so in this problem Alice
gets a vector X Bob gets a vector Y and
essentially they want to tell whether
the inner product between X and Y is at
least square root n or minus square root
n the way I phrased it I've traced it as
an xor problem here they want to compute
the uh they want to see if the xor of X
and Y has large Hamming weight or small
Hamming weight where this large and
small differ by square root n
so by having weight you should really
think of the plus ones as zero and ones
as minus ones
so this is the gap handling problem and
this is a very well studied problem and
there are a number of different proofs
that this problem requires Omega n
randomized communication
and one way of looking at this lower
bound is through coin theorems
so in yesterday's talk we saw what coin
theorems are but let me just briefly
recap them so the coin problem studies
what is the maximum advantage in
distinguishing biased coins from
unbiased coins
the coin theorem says that this maximum
Advantage is proportional to the level
one Fourier growth
it turns out that you can view this Gap
Hamming problem as a coin theorem for
the xor fibers of communication
protocols
so let me describe this a little more
carefully
so the point is if you have a
communication protocol
that computes the Gap Hamming
then the xor fiber
of this protocol
can distinguish between biased coins and
unbiased coins
where this bias is 1 over square root
10.
let me call this xor fiber h
so this implies that by the coin theorem
the level one growth of the xor fiber
must be large
so if you could show that the level of
free growth of XR fiber is bounded by
something in terms of the communication
complexity of the protocol it would give
you a lower bound on the communication
complexity of the protocol
so this is the connection of xor fibers
to the Gap handling problem
any questions about these applications
yeah so you give a new proof of this
um yeah
okay so now I'm ready to State our main
result
okay so the question here is what can we
say about the Fourier growth of xor
fibers
the conjecture is that the Fourier
growth of excel fibers behaves like the
Fourier growth of decision trees
in the sense that the level L Fourier
growth is at most square root D to the L
if your cost is T
this is still open
the best one we had prior to our work is
D to DL
as opposed to square root D to the L
and our work really tries to bridge this
gap between D to the Ln square root D to
b l
so for our first result we prove the
optimal level one bound of square root B
our second result is to improve the
level 2 bound from d square to D to the
1.5 we conjecture that the correct
answer is actually order d
so this is our main result
so as described before this result has
some applications
so the level one Bond gives you a new
proof of the Omega n lower bond for the
gap having problem
the level 2 bound
improves the lower Bond on the
communication version of the two-fold
formulation problem from n to the one
fourth point to the one third
the correct answer we suspect is square
root n and for that you would have to
prove optimal level to Fourier good
bounds
finally it also gives you a new proof
for the level one Bound for decision
trees and parity trees
so any questions about our results
so yeah
um so we think we can save a square root
D factor for higher levels which uh so I
think the main focus should be to
improve the level two bond to the
optimal thing because even if you
generalize it to higher levels you'll
just save a factor of square root of d
okay so
um now I'd like to tell you something
about the proof there are some very nice
ideas in this and hopefully I'll be able
to tell you some of them
um okay so the proof roughly consists of
three steps
so in the first step I'm going to view
this communication protocol and Fourier
growth through geometric lens
there's going to be some random
geometric process and we're going to
write some Martingale on this process
such that the final value of this
Martingale captures the Fourier growth
so this is going to be the first part
now what we want to do is bound the
final value of the smarting Gale and we
want to bond the expected square of the
Martingale to be more precise so to do
this you need to bound the sum of
squares or step sizes of the smarting
Guild
it turns out that this is hard to do for
General protocols so we are going to
assume that the protocol satisfies some
nice properties
and this nice property turns out to be
some kind of spectral notion of almost
Independence
I'll talk about this in a little I will
talk about this later and I'll also try
to give you some ideas as to why this is
the right notion that we care about when
trying to prove Fourier growth
and finally I'll try to justify this
assumption
that we make on the protocol why is it
the case that you can assume
communication protocols have this nice
structure and for this I'll give a
cleaner procedure to convert an
arbitrary communication protocol into a
protocol that satisfies these
assumptions furthermore this
communication protocol is not too much
bigger
this is the broad outline and at a very
high level this is very similar to how
the Fourier growth for parity decision
increase and decision tree works
there you don't need to use some
spectral notion of Independence you
can actually impose perfect
Independence and this is because
decision trees and very decision trees
are highly structured objects
but for communication protocols this is
much harder to do
so in particular if you look at the sets
that Alice and Bob have you know in the
middle of the protocol these sets could
be arbitrary subsets of the Boolean
hypercube it's going to be impossible to
enforce the sets to be independent
perfect tkwis independent so we can only
impose some approximate notion of
Independence and day priority it's not
even clear what this approximate notion
of Independence should look like
that is one of the key contributions of
this step which is what kind of
Independence we use
why it's useful
and it turns out that this cleanup
process is also highly non-trivial in
fact this is the most technically
involved part of our work where we show
that you know you can clean up this
protocol using very few steps
so yeah so this is the rough outline
now let me get into the details of the
proof
so let's start with step one for now I'm
just going to work with level one
so first oh yeah go ahead so yeah I
think I'm I'm confused about the
definition so what is the function what
is the domain and what is okay I think
it will help to probably write down this
definition and keep it through the talk
so you have a communication protocol
where analysis and Bob's inputs are plus
one minus 1 to the n
and the xor fiber
h
is
is plus minus 1 to the N to minus 1 1.
where H of Z
is the expectation of
see this okay
ah yes so here I'm identifying the
communication protocol with its output
I'm thinking of c f x y is the output
so as a picture it's just this
look at the fiber corresponding to Z
which is all the points X Y such that X
X or Y is z
and you take the average of the protocol
over this fiber you do this for every
fiber and call that function h
any other questions
so
let me start by describing the first
step
so here I am going to rephrase this
problem using a geometric perspective
I'm going to write down some Martingale
that captures the level one Fourier
growth
so first how do we think of a
communication protocol we think of it as
a tree so here I'm going to make a lot
of simplifying assumptions so Alice and
Bob are going to just send one bit at a
time and they're going to keep
exchanging they're going to keep taking
turns
so here is an example of such a
communication protocol where Alice
starts by revealing the value of her
first coordinate then Bob Reveals His
first coordinate and so on
based on the actual inputs they receive
they might go left or right so here is
an example of its input and here is the
part that you would follow on this input
finally at the leaf you have values one
or minus one and when the players each
leave they just announce this as the
answer
so this is what uh this is how we think
of a communication protocol
and this is a very special type of
communication protocol where the
information that Alice and Bob sent is
just the coordinates of their input
so this corresponds to a decision tree
like protocol
in general communication protocols can
be much more complicated
so at each point Alice can reveal f of x
where f is an arbitrary function of x
similarly Bob can reveal an arbitrary
function of his input
so this is the structure of General
communication protocols
from this talk there will be an
underlying Distribution on the inputs of
Alice and Bob and this is just the
uniform distribution
we're always going to sample the inputs
of Alice and Bob X and Y independently
and uniformly
and this is what introduces the
randomness into the process
this induces a random work on this tree
we're going to Define some Martingale
based on this random work
so now I'm going to give the geometric
picture
and the point is that you can view a
communication protocol as a partitioning
process of the input space
at the start you have the space of all
possible inputs which is plus one minus
the to the N times plus or minus 1 to
the n and as you go down this tree this
induces a partitioning process for the
space of all inputs
so in more detail if you are at some
node and let's say Alice is speaking
um so first of all at any node the set
of inputs that reach this node is going
to be a rectangle of the form a times B
where a is a subset of Alice's inputs
and these are some sort of Bob's inputs
when Alice speaks she's announcing f of
x and what this does is partition her
her set into two parts those for which f
of x is one those for which f of x is
minus one
so when Alice speaks she is partitioning
her set into two parts and when Bob
speaks he's partitioning his set into
two parts
so as you go down this tree you can
think of this process where one of the
players set is being partitioned into
two parts
and because the inputs are sampled
uniformly at random
each player is picking one of the parts
at random with probability proportional
to the measure of the part
there's also this random work that's
going on
foreign
growth is captured by the inner product
between Alice's Center and Bob's Center
so let me describe that in more detail
so give analysis and Bob sets you can
keep track of the center of the set so
the center is a geometry concept and you
can think of you know it has many
different names centroid Center of mass
all these things they're all the same
thing and they're defined by this
equation you sample a random point in
the set and look at the expected value
of that point this is an n-dimensional
vector and it captures the center of the
set
we're going to keep track of Alice's
Center and Bob Center as you go down
this protocol
first you can see that these centers U
and B are vector valued martingales in
the sense that if you take a set and you
divide it into two parts if you look at
the average of the two centers you're
going to get back the original Center
so the centers are themselves
martingales
we're going to look at the inner product
between the two centers
it turns out that this is also a
Martingale
and the reason is because when Alice
speaks she is modifying her Center but
Bob Center stays the same so only this
part changes and when Bob speaks only
his Center changes Alice's Center does
not change
so as a result the inner product between
analysis Center and Bob Center is also a
Martingale
in particular if you look at the final
value of the Martingale it gives you a
bond on the level one Fourier growth
if you look at the expected modulus of
this Martingale at the last at the end
this is a bound on the level one Fourier
growth
so I will justify this in the next slide
but are there any questions about the
setup
sorry
um
convex in the sense that if you take an
average of communication protocols then
everyone forget growth is bounded by the
average of 11 months so it's for places
to work with the demolistic protocols
okay
so let me justify this connection
between the level one Fourier both the
text of fiber and this inner product
will be in the sentence
um
so
essentially the idea is to just focus on
rectangles since any protocol can be
broken up into rectangles let's just see
the connection between the Fourier
growth of xor fiber of a rectangle and
this quantity
so the basic idea is the following three
facts so the first fact is if you take a
rectangle a times B
and you compute the xor fiber of the
rectangle so here when I say xor fiber
of a rectangle I just mean think of
these as the indicator functions of
Alice's and Bob sets up to some
normalization
if you compute the xor fiber for
rectangle it's precisely the convolution
of A and B
this just follows from the definition of
an xor fiber
so for a rectangle a times B the
convolution the xor fiber is just a star
B and the second fact is that the
Fourier coefficients of the convolution
are products of Fourier coefficients
this is a very simple fact in Fourier
analysis
finally this Vector here the level one
Fourier so if you take a set and write
down the level one Fourier coefficients
is a vector this is exactly capturing
the center of a set
this is also something that's a very
simple fact you can write down the
Fourier coefficients and the level one
coefficients are captured by the center
of the set
so together these three facts imply that
if you look at the xor fiber of a
rectangle a times p and you just add up
all the level one Fourier coefficients
you get this inner product between the
center of the Alice set and the center
of Bob set
there's some cheating I've done here
which is ignore the signs on the level
on Fourier growth but this can be done
okay
so this is just the way to view the
level one Fourier growth as this
geometric concept so now I'm going to
restate the whole problem completely
geometrically so even if you missed out
the Fourier growth in xr5 version now is
a good time to jump back in
so here is the main problem that
question we have this random geometric
process of partitioning the input space
so first Alice partitions are set into
two parts and she chooses a random part
with probability proportional to the
measure of that part
based on this Bob partitions his set
into two parts and chooses one part at
random with probability proportional to
the measure
then Alice does this again
and what business again and at each step
we keep track of the centers of the
resulting sets
this partitioning process is adaptive in
the sense that the way the players
partitioned their set can depend on the
history up till this point
and what we want to do so they do this D
times and what we want to show is that
the final Center of Alice that and Bob
sets are not too correlated
more precisely we are looking at the
inner product between Alice's Center and
Bob Center in the end we want to show
that the expected modulus of that is
small
it's at most Square would be
so this is just a restatement of the
level one for your equipment in this
picture
um
yeah so looking ahead it will turn out
that each of these vectors is roughly
square root D bits long so this inner
product could potentially be as large as
T but what we want to say the typically
is that typically it's at most Square
would be
so let me describe this in the next
slide
you can show that this smarting layer
that we care about can be bounded by
order D in the worst case that is for
every leaf of this protocol this
Martingale is at most order d
and the justification of it is is the
following so you can just bound this by
Kashi Schwartz by the product of the
norms
and the point is each of these
quantities is going to be at most square
root d by an application of the level
one inequality
so what is a level one inequality say it
says it if you are given a set in the
Boolean hypercube that is not too small
then its Center cannot be too far from
the origin
in particular if you have a set of
measure 2 to the minus t its Center is
at most square root D away from the
origin
and because U and B are the center of
Alice's and Bob sets and in a protocol
you can kind of assume that Alexis and
Bob sits and the leaf have measure at
least 2 to the minus t it follows that
each of these centers is at most square
root D long and this gives you the order
of D bump
what we really want to show is that
typically it's at most square root B so
we will show that the expected square of
this uh final Martingale is at most
orderly
this would imply by koshy Schwartz the
bond that we want
so is this optimal for partitions if I
don't consider protocols but just
partitioning exactly exactly so we're
really using the fact that there's a
Martingale going on which doesn't happen
if you just have an arbitrary partition
what do you think the answer is the
partitions oh that's a good question
um
I think that you know the first round is
tight
because there's no kind of Martingale
cancellation Behavior going on
but I don't know
so what's happening here is that
um these vectors U and B can be square
root D which long but on average they're
going to be close to orthogonal
that's what we're going to show
um let's see an example of this to make
things concrete so let's look at a
simple communication with a call where
Alice and Bob are simply revealing the
first B coordinates this effectively
partitions the input space into sub
cubes
if you look at the leftmost part
then Alice and Bob are setting their
first the coordinates to be one
in this case the resulting sets are
basically all points whose first e
coordinates are one the centers of such
sets is basically this point where the
first D coordinates are one and the rest
are zero
now if you compute the inner product
between these two centers it's going to
be D
so this is saying that the first Bond we
derived is tight for a worst case leaf
but the point is when you take a random
Leaf you're going to get cancellations
so when you take a random Leaf the
values you said to Alice's coordinates
in Bob's coordinates are going to be
independent because these inputs were
sampled independently
and as a result you are going to set the
first equivalence of Alice to be a and
Bob to BB
so when you compute the per inner
product between the centers you're going
to get the inner product between A and B
which is typically square root B
so this really highlights the phenomenon
of cancellations that occur when you
take a random path
the intuition is that when you sample X
and Y independently the resulting u and
v the centers of Alice's in Bob shed
should be kind of independent in the
sense they should be kind of orthogonal
this is not true because the centers can
be highly correlated as a result of the
communication protocol nevertheless we
want to say that typically they're
roughly orthogonal
this is the kind of statement that we
want to prove regardless of what kind of
communication the players send then no
matter how they partition the protocol
so this is the problem any equations at
this point yeah I mean everything is
interestingly in general except for the
I guess the part you're going to do
that's the like you need to shove it at
every step the square is smaller like
the sum of the squares
the quadratic variation
yes but this turns out to be
surprisingly hard so I think so we'll
see what the calculation for the step
size is and we can see why it's so hard
about these websites at each point
hopefully I'll be able to answer your
question
yes so the inner product of the centers
is exactly capturing the level one
Fourier growth effects of fiber so
this is the thing that I didn't fully
prove
which is that um
it's actually a really simple
calculation but um
so I did I kind of hinted at this
calculation for rectangles but we can go
over it again so here if you take if you
just look at the particular rectangle in
the protocol and you compute the xor
fiber the xor fiber is just going to be
the convolution of the two sides
and if you take the Fourier coefficient
of the convolution it's going to be the
product of Fourier coefficients
so these are the Fourier coefficients
and now you're adding all the level one
Fourier coefficients so you get
summation a hat IB hat I for all I and
this is a hat I is just captured by the
center of a
so it's just taking the inner product
between the center of a and the center
of B
yes so if you're looking at like level
two it would be over here exactly
exactly so it would be the expectation
of X tensor X
so um okay so now let me move on to step
two which is how do we Bond the sum of
squares of Step sizes and this turns out
to be a hard problem and we need to make
some assumptions on the protocol
namely we are going to Define some
spectral notion of two wise Independence
and show that under this assumption you
can burn the sum of squares or step
sizes so let's see what this is so first
let me try to uh tell you ahead what
we're going to do so you have the
smarting Guild this inner product
between analysis Center and Bob Center
we want to show that the sum of squares
or step sizes of this Martingale is
small
so let's compute the step sizes
so at time I if Alice is speaking only
her Center is going to change and let's
call the change in her Center as UI Plus
1.
the change in the Martingale is going to
be this inner product
now if Bob is speaking only his Center
is going to change and we're going to
call Vi plus 1 the change in his Center
and the change in the Martingale is
going to be this inner product
and we really want to bond the sum of
squares or strip sizes so let's see what
Bond we can prove
so assume that each step this change in
the center of mass is just a unit Vector
this is a simplifying assumption but
it's not so important so at each point
Alice and Bob are just adding a unit
Vector to their Center of mass in this
case if you apply cautious words you
just get a bound of Step sizes at most
the norm of analysis Center and the norm
of Polish Bob Center so this is just
cautious words
but this is not good enough
so we already showed that each of these
things is at most square root I by the
level 1 inequality and this is also
tight so the example we saw before
actually shows that this bond is tight
so then what happens is that each step
size can be as bad as square root I so
when you add the square of stabilizers
from 1 to D you get d square
so even to bound the step size is
assuming these nice assumptions it's you
know it's not clear how to do it
and this is the key step
we're going to show that if Alice's and
Bob sits satisfy this nice spectral two
wise Independence property
then you can bound the step size by the
change in Bob Center and by the change
analysis Center in the previous round
this might look a little comprehendative
so we're looking at the step size at
time I we're going to bound this by the
change in Bob Center in the previous
round
and similarly we are going to bound this
by the change in Alice's Center in the
previous round
this is what we are going to do
and if you can do this then we're in
good shape basically if you add this up
overall I it's going to be at most order
d
so
so now let me Define what the spectral
twice Independence is
we say that a set s is elongated in
Direction V is the variance of that set
in the direction is large
so you look at the projection of the set
on this direction B which is this random
variable x dot T where X Is uniformly
Random from s if this random variable
has large variance we say that a set is
elongated in this direction
pictorial is just this thing you have
this set which is elongated in this
direction and you have this set which is
not elongated in any direction
so this is what this is trying to
capture
we say that a set s is spectrally two
wise independent if it is not elongated
in any direction
it's another way to say this which is
look at the covariance Matrix of a
random Point sampled from s
this covariance Matrix must have small
spectral Norm
so this is what we mean by speculative
wise independent and it turns out that
if you can ensure that Alice's and Bob
sets are specially independent
throughout the protocol then you can
derive a bond on the Martingale step
sizes
so now I'll try to justify why this is
the case why is this a property we
should care about
so any questions about the definition of
spectral Independence
so why is this concept so useful
okay so here I'm going to introduce an
imaginary communication step you know
just imagine that Alice is going to
reveal the inner product of her input
with Bob Center
so she's going to send Bob the inner
product of X with V where V is Bob's
current Center
we call this the gramsment step
so I'm doing some cheating here this is
a real number so what does it mean to
send this real number there are two ways
of handling it so one you can round this
real number to some precision and send
the finite version of this but it turns
out that this introduces some errors and
you won't get the optimal level one
you'll get some login factors so in
order to get the precise bound we really
need to let Alice send the real number
to Bob
but this forces the inputs also to be
real because if x was Boolean revealing
x dot V could end up revealing X so we
really need to allow the inputs X also
to be real and that's why for the level
one boundary allow protocols with real
inputs and real communication and this
is what gives us the optimal level or
not but I'm not going to get into this
and for this talk you can just keep
either picture in mind
okay so what is this step doing this
Alice has a set a she's looking at this
direction and she's slicing her set into
slices based slices along this direction
so that's what this step is doing
why is this such an interesting step
so it will turn out that the change in
the Martingale as a result of this step
is precisely equal to how elongated
analysis set is in the direction V
so this gram switch step is what
connects the change in the Martingale to
the elongatedness of the set
so that's the power of this crampshit
step
so let's let's see why this is true it's
not too hard to see
so what is the change in the Martingale
so this is the expected change in the
Martingale as a result of this step so
what is this quantity so this is the
value of the Martingale at time I Plus
1. this is the value of the Martingale
at time I and we're Computing the
difference between the expected squares
so this is the step size Square
and now I'm just going to replace the
center by the definition of the center
so this U is basically the expectation
of a random Point sampled from Alice so
here I'm just replacing U by its
definition and replacing you here by its
definition
and the key Point here is that for every
Point within this slice it has the same
inner product with v
so for every point x dot b here when you
take X within the same size it's
actually the same so here this
expectation is actually over a constant
so you can pull the Square from outside
to inside and you just get the expected
square of this inner product
and now this quantity by definition is
the variance of Alice is set in the
direction B
so
so the details here are not so important
the point is that this gramsment step
expresses the change in the Martingale
in terms of the elongatedness of the set
in Direction V
so this almost gives us what we want so
what do we actually have to do we're
actually going to introduce this gram
Schmidt Step at every node in the
protocol so you take the original
protocol whenever Alice is supposed to
say something we're going to first tell
her to do this gramshulous step and then
do whatever she was supposed to do
the advantage of doing this is first you
can express the change in the Martingale
during this step as a measure of how
elongated Alice is set is in this
direction V at most I and this direction
is Bob's current Center
and what's interesting is that we did
this gram Smith step before as a result
of which the variance of Alice is it in
this direction equals the variance of
Alice is set in this direction where v i
is the change in Bob's Center
so why is this the case the point is
here Alice has revealed the inner
product with Bob's old Center
so by the time you reach here the inner
product with Bob's old Center is already
fixed
that means the variance of this set
along that old Center is zero
so when you compute the variance along
this direction you might as well
subtract Bob's old Center because the
variance along the direction is zero
so as a result the variance along this
direction equals the variance along the
change in Bob's Center
um
so in the real it's usually that won't
happen you'll have slices so you can
talk about a later measure
so we do have to talk about like
relative measure within the Subspace
or just the
um yeah just the gaussian measure on the
space so if you have the gaussian
measure on the full space and you look
at a Subspace it induces a gaussian
measure on one less Dimension and you
look at that measure this measure of the
set under that caution
so you're measuring the intersection of
the rectangle with the skeleton with the
Subspace yes
this
is
so now the point is that the expressive
variance and reduction in terms of the
variance and change in balance in change
in Bob Center and now we're in good
shape this is what we wanted we wanted
to say that if Alice is so because Alice
is set is two Y is independent the
variance in this direction is at most
the norm square of this direction and
this is the change in Bob's previous
Center
Okay so
so the point of this step is that you
can bound the change in the Martingale
in this step using two wise Independence
and it turns out that this gram switch
step has this nice property that the
other steps don't contribute anything to
the Martingale and this is really why we
call this the gram switch step
the point is at this stage Alice has
revealed the inner product with Bob
Center
so any further change in her Center is
going to be orthogonal to Bob Center
so the Martin here material here is
going to not change at all
okay so let me summarize what happened
here we introduced this nice property
called two wise Independence which means
that a set is not elongated in any
direction
we introduced this gramshman step which
connects the change in the Martingale
with the elongatedness of a set we said
that if a set is not elongated then you
can control the jumps in this particle
so the whole problem becomes how do you
ensure that these sets are not elongated
in any direction
so now I'm going to move on to the third
part which is how do you ensure that the
sets are not elongated in any direction
so any questions about step two
so now um this is kind of an independent
question on its own so even if you
didn't follow step two step three can
make sense on its own so here the
problem is you have a set that is not
clean it's elongated in many directions
how do you partition the set so that
it's not elongated in any direction
there's a very natural trainer process
every time you have a set like this
which is elongated in this direction you
simply slice it up along the direction
this is again kind of like a gramsment
step but the vector you choose is the
direction along which your set is
elongated
and the advantage of doing this is that
within each slice
the variance in Direction B is zero
so now the question becomes how many
times do you have to do this process
so this is the main technical Emma in
our paper
we show that for a communication
protocol of cost D you can clean it up
using typically ordered D steps
so all of Alice's and Bob's rectangles
can be cleaned up using just a constant
blob in the communication cost
this is our main Lemma
let me tell you a special case of this
minimum which is actually uh proved in a
work by tomovidic
so this says that if you have a set
that's not too small
then it cannot be elongated in too many
directions
in particular if your measure of the set
is 2 to the minus t then there can be at
most ordered D orthonormal directions
along which your set is elongated
this can be proved using some kind of a
suit structure versus student or some
density increment argument
the point is that every time your set is
elongated in some direction that
direction gives you at least one bit of
information about that set
so when you slice up the set along the
direction and you take a random slice
the relative density of the set goes up
it at least doubles at each step and
since the original measure of the set is
2 to the minus t you cannot do this
doubling more than D times
so that's the idea behind this slimmer
um
the general case is significantly more
complicated and let me try to tell you
why
so first we need to clean up every
internal node of this protocol it
doesn't just suffice to clean up the
leaves
so what happens is that this
partitioning and cleaning process occur
in an interleaved fashion so first Alice
is going to partition her set then
you're going to clean it up then again
Alice is going to partition I said clean
it up and so on so we really need an
Adaptive version of the screen of
process
secondly cleaning a set might produce
new bad directions
so here is an example of a set that is
only elongated in this direction you
know assume that the measure of this
slice is small but when you slice it up
and you take this slice it's going to be
elongated in this direction
so our cleanup process really needs to
handle all this and that's what makes
this more Technical and nevertheless
we're able to do this
so this is what I wanted to say about
the cleanup process
finally let me tell you about the level
2 bound
so as nikhil said you can do some
similar things where you look at the
level 2 Center so you look at
expectation of extensor X and you know
all this Martingale Behavior turns out
to be true but the hard step is the
screening process so let me tell you
what we need to clean and how much we're
able to clean it
um
so what happens for level L equals two
so the notion of clean turns out to be
this
we say that a set s is elongated along a
bilinear form if you look at this random
variable in a product between X tensor X
and V this is some bilinear form
if the variance of this quantity is
large we say that a set is elongated in
this bilinear form
we say that a set is respectively four Y
is independent if it is not elongated in
any bilinear form so any perfectly
forward independent set is also
respectively for wise independent and
this is the property that we want
Alice's and Bob sets to satisfy
and here is what we need to do given any
set that is not too small
we want to show that you can partition
it into a few parts such that a typical
part is spectrally four wise independent
so the measure is 2 to the minus t you
want to partition it into two to the
departs such that each part is
spectrally four wise independent
of course we will eventually need an
Adaptive version of this and so on but
this is the main question
and the difficulties in some sense that
this baby lamas no longer true
you can have sets whose measure is like
2 to the minus t but there are D Squared
bilinear forms along which the set is
elongated
and really this is the example
but the key Point here is that even
though there are so many bilinear firms
there are actually these deep pieces of
information that once you fix these D
pieces of information it kills off all
these D Squared bilinear forms
so that's the hope and maybe there is
some other way of partitioning so that
you know you can still do this
so let me tell you a little bit about
what we do to get this D to the three
halves bound
essentially we modify this definition of
cleanliness to be 10 times d
and then it turns out that there are at
most D bilinear forms along which your
set is elongated so our notion of clean
is D times bigger than what it should be
and this essentially gives us a d times
uh the correct sum of squares or step
sizes
so
um
so let me end my talk here other happy
to take questions now
okay
repeat a question because so what can
you say about partitions and rectangles
[Music]
yeah I don't know I would expect that
there's no kind of Martin game process
going on so I would think that already
is the right answer I don't have an
example in mind but I would think that
you can't withdraw on this
exact question is
it should be like uh pretty equivalent
to asking like about the partnership
number of the Gap handling model right
um
so I think the Japan
actually through using some kind of
partition Bond they say that it takes
any rectangle of measure 2 to the minus
t
then you get some contradiction
such an argument necessarily doesn't use
anything more than the fact that you
have a small partition
so I think the gap having a robot
actually you know you get some kind of
partitioned about
number of particles
so
I'm not sure yeah
so it seems you're you're kind of bound
cannot be proved for a single record
only for partitions but it potentially
could be proved for about
it I mean
it could be yeah
I mean if it's possible maybe maybe
there are still translated I don't see
why yeah I I don't know
any more questions
okay if not let's take Uber again